To be an athlete, musician, or even the best player, you have to practice uninterruptedly. But
to what extent did talent come into play? Are some of us born with one
the best chance of being the best in what we do?
To study this question in sports, scientists have tried to give it to untrained people
the same exercise, to see if the same amount of training will lead to different results.
Not so strange, different individuals had different improvements - some improved
in big leaps while others seemed stagnant. But interesting, individuals who are connected
by blood had similar improvements, shows that their genetics play a role in
their athletic potential. If your parent or brother / sister brings up terrible results from the training,
so would you. These individuals are considered 'high responsive' in exercises.
After the statistical analysis of patience, it was determined that 50% of the athletic improvement
was related to genetics. In other words, big athletes are born with large genes.
Over time, scientists have been able to isolate specific groups of genes they believe
that they are responsible for these features. The high reactors have it and the experience of visible enhancer,
no matter how willing they are to start. Conversely, if your genes are considered 'responsive'
poor 'for endurance training, skiing sport may not be for you.
But even before training, scientists notice something else; there were also individuals who had
different starting points. Without any training, some individuals were simply
more capable than others. It turns out, a different set of genes give some people a higher starting point.
In the case of endurance, these genes can encode for large volumes of blood, which in
generally seen only by trained athletes.
So you may have a high starting point or high-skill training - or both! And this is likely to be our greatest athletes
trained as strictly as they could, at the head of having some great genetics.
It seems that talent is trained under the right circumstances.
So you got what you need to be an Olympic athlete? Science says, you will never know until
try it.
Remember: we have a new video coming out every day of the Olympics.
Can not you wait? Our amazing CBC partners already have five of the videos so far for you.
Just go to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to see them before someone else. Below the description in the video.
But we also want to know your own questions about this particular series. Use the hashtag of ScienceSays and tell us your fiery Olympic questions.
And subscribe to more impressive science videos!